a year ago they didn't expect to fill
these graves with covid dead
they were hopelessly wrong today
all of these graves are full all the
extra graves they dug are full
and they're still digging more brazil's
covert death rate is staggering its
infection rate astonishing
but brazil's coveted variant is wreaking
havoc
amongst an unexpected group pregnant
women
ezekiel was born 12 weeks prematurely
his mother
tyus had been intubated covid
overwhelmed her in days
she was fit and healthy ezekiel was
delivered by cesarean section
he's only just come home
like most people taiyus and her family
thought she was in no danger when the
first symptoms developed
but they were wrong when her kidneys
failed
the doctor said she wouldn't live
[Music]
ezekiel was treated in this maternity
ward the death rate for
pregnant women in brazil was already
poor
it's 55 per 100 000 women
in britain the figure is just 9.7
but experts here say that with kovid the
new number could double to over
100 per 100 000 right now
42 pregnant women every week die of
covid
doctors on the front line say it's down
to the p1 variant
douglas silverio has three children now
his youngest is maria helena she is
three months old
he's bringing him up with the help of
his mother-in-law and family friends
his wife vanessa was killed by covid she
was just 33 when she was intubated
and maria helena was delivered
coincidentally on her dad's birthday
vanessa didn't make it on the day
douglas held mass for his wife's death
baby maria helena was released from
hospital
he wants everyone to fear kovid and to
listen
i miss my wife she was my friend
we had some a lot of friends but
yeah i said i i got scared when i see on
the streets some pregnant woman
without mess because i said please take
care of herself
the cue for the vaccination program is
slow they're only just getting to 56
year olds
the new vulnerable young pregnant women
are way down the line
out of ideas the overwhelmed health
authority here
has come up with a plan they're telling
women not to get pregnant
stuart ramsey sky news sao paulo